police used tear gas and stun grenades
to break up a march by students and
trade unions in the capital quito the
protesters want the government to reduce
the cost of fuel and to reverse the
privatization of public services our
latin america editor lucia newman
reports
this is the beginning of a national
strike that could paralyze ecuador
the mobilization is national it's
regional and the mobilization is
indefinite if the president gives us
answers today then we will stop if the
president does not give answers to any
of our demands then we will continue
indefinitely
demonstrations led by ecuador's powerful
indigenous confederation almost three
years ago nearly overthrew
then-president lenin moreno forcing him
to backtrack on plans to raise fuel
prices
today their demands are far greater
not only do these protesters want fuel
prices lowered and frozen but they also
want the same for essential goods and
services
we're literally starving to death there
is no work farm products are minimized
there is no proper support from the
government with the rise in fewer prices
everything is more expensive
the government doesn't hear us does it
hear the poor farmers no it doesn't does
it know the price of fertilizers no and
our products are already cheap how are
we going to survive to feed our children
roads are being blocked in at least 10
of ecuador's 24 provinces conservative
president guillermo lasso says he will
not tolerate further disruptions
just now as we were beginning to get
back on our feet from the pandemic we
cannot allow political groups who wanted
to stabilize ecuador and profit from the
chaos paralyze our country
the government is already struggling to
control rampant violence and drug
trafficking amid a severe economic
crisis
but unless there's a breakthrough the
strike by the well-organized indigenous
confederation with the support of other
trade unions could present the most
serious challenge to ecuador's stability
lucian newman al jazeera